ladies and gentlemen we have yet another
crypto
scam that i want to talk to you guys
about today we're here
in the 10 million dollar studio because
i know i know
you want the lambo you want the
lifestyle
but ladies and gentlemen you got to be
careful out there because there are
wolves
out in the crypto dark woods okay you
got to be careful
now let's go to the board i want to show
you what happened today ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio
i'm your host as usual and we're talking
about a very sad story
okay the these guys came out with a 32
million dollar rug pull
it's this d5 100 token okay but the
worst part is
is well maybe maybe it's not the worst
part i i mean
they just were honest i'm going to be
i'm going to be straight up with you a
lot of scams they don't they're not
honest
uh this one was they linked after they
ran away with everyone's funds
people put a ton of money into this new
token called d5 100 as you can see right
here
they left a note to everybody on their
now defunct web page the web host shut
it down so you have to go to an archive
to see this they said
we scammed you guys and you can't do
about it
ha ha all you moon boys have been
scammed and you can't do
about it devson now i'm just gonna be
completely transparent with you guys
i spent yesterday hunting this person
down
to no avail i mean there are a lot of uh
kind of dead leads all around even a guy
got doxxed by somebody thinking that it
was this guy
it wasn't it was just someone who had
forked the github repo
it's a long story but the point is is
that we have no idea who did this
it's a sad story in crypto when you
honestly you have these projects
get propped up by anonymous developers
and people
invest in them and they end up getting
absolutely screwed look at this
what are you gonna do i mean in some
ways it i hate to say it but he's right
i mean what are you gonna do we have no
idea who this was it was an anonymous
uh developer from the start and yet
people ran
to this scheme and the frustrating thing
for me is i try to educate people about
scams
look the red flags were there right you
never
invest in something where the developers
aren't known even women developers are
known by the way you still can lose your
money so that doesn't even help you but
especially when the developers are
unknown that's a really big
red flag that this project's probably uh
gonna fail again the project can still
fail even if the developers are well
known
but i just feel like there's so much
hype in the crypto community i mean
obviously right now we're in a huge dip
but there's so much uh you know fomo of
you just want to jump in what's the next
bitcoin what's the next big thing
and these unscrupulous marketers can get
away with
murder because honestly they can just
jump in promise you the world
and people fall for it now when we go to
their coin gecko which is basically
just tracking uh tracking the coin as
you can see here
in the chart initially it was started
really high
it almost immediately uh fell apart now
this is a lot of thing a lot of people
don't know is that this project had been
basically defunct for months and nobody
had really been trading it
but the developer just hadn't told
everyone that it was a scam yet
now the crazy thing is is that you can
even see there was a little bit of
interest here
now at this point it's a total scam but
nobody had been told yet and so uh
finally people were told and that
eventually it's gonna drop to zero
because the developer ran away with
everyone's money but this just
this is like a perfect chart of human
greed people jump in because they think
they're at
the next big thing it nobody's
developing it right
uh so that interest dies but even you
just see a bunch of
this is just a bunch of fomo people
throwing money at this project
after it's already collapsed i mean it's
unbelievable to me it's like
the project might as well have declared
bankruptcy and people are still throwing
money at it it just makes no sense
and i feel like a lot of it's because so
many investors are getting involved in
crypto who haven't
really gotten burned yet and so they're
running into these projects thinking
that they're safe
or at least they're thinking that they
have a really good chance of doing well
and obviously they get they get wrecked
this is yet another reason people say i
mean i know it's a trope but it's
serious that like
you never want to invest money you can't
lose into these projects
because it happens that people really do
lose it i mean that's not just like a
saying i mean
especially in crypto you can lose all
your money especially on these um
decentralized exchanges right people
oftentimes will create
tokens that they'll say you need to
trade in your eth for my token
now what people don't realize is that
their eth is valuable
usually the token they're exchanging it
for is not they'll promise you huge
yields they'll promise you huge uh
returns that you gotta be first in
but oftentimes what they're after is the
etherium that you're gonna trade
for their token and then they run away
with it it's really sad to watch
people get away with this stuff over and
over and over and over again listen
people
know uh people who aren't new to the
crypto community know that this has been
happening for some time
actually i believe this project was bcs
binance smart chain
but uh very similar they i mean they
want b and b instead of ethereum but the
point is guys we've been here before i
mean uh an old crypto scam
named prodium.io they disappeared
and they left instead of saying we
scammed you they just left a single word
on their website penis
yes that's right ladies and gentlemen in
all its glory here's another exit scam
it just shocks me um how much money
these people end up making from this
stuff and it makes me really sad
because again you can't find them you're
not gonna get justice a lot of the
crypto
currency community there's not there's
no oversight there's no regulation
right the sec is not going to get them
when elon musk tweets
and manipulates the market the sec is
not going to get them so uh
you really got to be careful and i say
that personally i
like to lose my money the old-fashioned
way which is in the cryptocurrency
market the normal market bitcoin where i
can lose 30 in you know one week that's
what i like to do
don't don't lose 100 like crypto's
already volatile enough is what i try to
tell people it's like if you want risk
crypto's the place for risk you don't
need to go into all coins
i mean you're really playing with fire
people get involved in leverage people
get involved in all these crazy things
they don't really understand
they get in projects they don't
understand they uh they join developer
teams or they join a coin with
developers who they don't know
and they really get in deep water fast
trust me crypto
is volatile enough ladies and gentlemen
you don't need you don't need all these
weird
alt coins created yesterday to make it
even more risky
that being said you guys can do whatever
you want if you want to go to these
sketchy exchanges and get these sketchy
coins you know what
there's risk there's a reward but be
warned
among like honest risk of just whether
the coin succeeds or not
there are scammers just want to take
advantage of you
that's the fact and if you're not
prepared to see a message
like this on the website of your
favorite altcoin
maybe think twice so uh that's pretty
much
it just wanted to cover this real quick
thanks for watching i'll see you guys in
the next one